Molten aluminium causes ice to explode and molten copper casts an ingot that tunnels down through ice
We've got a bunch of bullets that we want to melt down to see what happens with molten brass, in clear ice
Here's the basic idea
We have a lot of shells we've collected from a gun range that we can melt in our foundry until they're completely liquid
We know that molten aluminium in a block of ice will make it explode but brass is over three times heavier than aluminium
And has a much higher melting point. So will it react differently than aluminium or will the ice still explode?
It amazes me how easily this ice carves this is just a super cheap low-quality knife
It's not even very sharp because it's the clear ice
It's uniform thickness and density all the way through so it doesn't have a tendency to crack
When you hit air pockets or anything because there are no air pockets and I'm carving this out just so there's sort of a funnel
So that if I am not perfect with my aim the molten brass will still end up right where I want it
that's so weird
Okay, it's in.
Ready? Three, Two, One
Ooh! Volcano
Oh my gosh
(laughter)
It didn't crack, it didn't break, which is what we've seen happen with the aluminium
But it also didn't do what we've seen with the copper at least not entirely. We had a brass volcano
shooting molten metal up into the air.
Oh and some of it did start tunneling down through
there was some that didn't spurt out and that just tunneled all the way down through
We watched it filling up with water
As it was just being melted by the heat and then once it tunneled all the way through the bottom of ice, all that water
drained right out. Oh shoot. I think the GoPro got some molten brass on it
It's still counting. So it's still working
But yeah the surface of this
camera has been quite thoroughly melted.
I don't know how well you can see this, but it is still going
points to GoPro on that one way to go we did go GoPro
I'm funny
That is really interesting
copper tunneled its way down through and brass which is mostly made of copper tunnels its way down through
neither of them caused the ice to crack or explode the way aluminum does
I've got a really good eruption of this brass though. That was fantastic.
Well, there is our cast brass ingot
You can see through the side
compared to how narrow that little drilled channel was
It's just like carved its way right down through
widening it all the way as it went, until it reached the bottom and then just dumped out all the liquid in it
I don't know if it's just coincidence or not at the bottom of this ingot is still sort of the shape of the drill hole
When I drill into the ice using this spade bit
it makes one lowest point and then just generally a flatter area and the bottom of our brass ingot that we've just cast is
almost that same shape. So I'm wondering if that's solidified first and then the heat of the other brass behind it
just kept it hot enough to keep melting its way down through
Our brass tunneled really well through a block of ice but it survived you can't have that.
First, i'm going to try taking this heavy chunk of brass and throwing it down at the block of ice as hard as I can and
If that doesn't work
I've got Bessie here
It didn't destroy the whole block but it did crack a lot of it down through there. It's pretty neat.
Bessie's Turn!
That is so satisfying
That was really cool. We got a result
we have not had before, which was seriously just this geyser of the molten metal flying up out of the top
We've now had different results with aluminum, copper, and brass. What else should we try?
Guys, that's not all, there's more for you to see that little box up at the top will transport you directly to our last video
Go watch it!
The little box at the bottom will show you what YouTube thinks you should be watching next and if you hit this bomb here in the middle
you'll be subscribed to our channel. So you never miss a video
don't forget to ring that bell and we will see you in the next one. Talk to you then.